clearly you've drawn the through line
between the the younger child and how it
affects the parents so now let's move
right into the middle or backspace let's
go to college which is where you spend
most of your time writing your books
researching so basically you feel that
colleges have become these places to
just chase grades chase credits chase
these imaginary things but they don't
really make you a better person or more
functional in society or a better member
of a productive society that Thursday I
think it is but I think you're almost
being too positive
take it away well I was taught in school
very young to be positive I mean I think
there's an element of truth in what
you're saying that people go there and
now I think with the far more
instrumental attitude about in terms of
getting credit and getting great I mean
the question that every single academic
hates more than any other question is
will this be on the exam yeah you know
is this relevant for our end of town
paper or are we going to be assessed on
this and you can see if a student has
say ten lectures in a series they will
look and they will see which ones are
going to be relevant to the exam or
relevant to the essay and they only turn
up for those once in the attendants are
really dear mm-hmm but you know I think
universities do so much in terms of
encouraging this attitude among students
so most universities go back 10 20 years
ago would have certainly in the UK mid
semester there would be a Reading Week
and the expectation would be that there
were no classes that week and students
were expected to go to the library to
read or under subject now lots of
universities that's been changed and
it's not called reading week anymore
it's called employability week and they
get people coming in from local
businesses and from kind of national
corporations and telling students what
they need to do to
why for a job in a particular area do
you know what the students mainly just
avoid these things that's because I
think the students have got a bit of
common sense and kind of over not
terribly interested in just thinking
about that or I think well I've got a
few years yet and I don't know what I
definitely want to do yeah but the
universities are sending out the message
to students from day one you know you're
here to get a job this is all that it's
about essentially it's about job
training and the really sad thing is I
think lots of students arrive at
university with some interest in the
subject that they're going to study and
some genuine desire to want to know
about that subject and I think something
happens when there aren't university
either explicitly or implicitly when
they pick up on this message it's all
about the grades it's all about just
ticking the boxes of what you have to do
and it's all about getting these
employability skills on this piece of
paper that you can take when you don't
get a job yeah how absurd does it seem
to you that when you so you take these
kids they come from this this sort of
over regulated system you've protected
them from certain ideas you then put
them in a system where the grade is the
ultimate goal I know I would say almost
everyone that I know that I think is a
good functioning person of society has
either changed their career or is now
major didn't one thing and is doing
something else I was a political science
major I just said to Larry King earlier
I said I may be the only one that's
using this thing actually the way it was
supposed to be used but that the idea
that at 18 after whatever education
you've had even if it was perfect in
your world that at 18 to 24 or something
you should be able to figure out what
you can do for there steal it what what
a sad state of humanity that is hell
it's a sad state of humanity it's also a
sad state of education because
essentially it means the university is a
job training center and that that
removes any quality any value from
higher education but you know where I
think this is what I'm saying I think
you're being a bit too optimistic
because I think yeah there are some
students who are just chasing the grains
for a lot of academics it's actually
they don't like and I sympathize with
them with this completely they don't
like the idea that they are teaching
employability skills you know this is
kind of neoliberal right they buzz load
and they don't want to think that
they're operating within this kind of
marketing system and they're just
training people up to go and get a job
and cash in what's it's known as the
Graduate premium and you can go and get
your kind of extra wages because you've
got this degree certificate but the
problem is then in opposition to that
doesn't stand let's teach subject
knowledge let's take all this wonderful
the best that's been thought and said
and let's share this with students in
opposition to the kind of employability
certificates grades stands this values
agenda again so this is very very
similar to what's going on in the
schools it happens in higher education
too so it's things like global
citizenship responsibility for
protecting the environment again you get
the sex education the consent classes
and all of these ideas about how to be a
good person essentially but not work out
for yourself what you think is being a
good person but it's somebody else's
idea right so in a itself those those
those topics you're not against those
topics being taught but but it's the way
that it's all sort of being put together
and you have no problem with learning
about how to be a good citizen or
something you don't know you go to
university to have someone teach you how
to be a good citizen they can teach you
knowledge again for you to think
critically about for you to come to your
own conclusions about but the problem is
when universities trying to teach you
directly how to be a good person how to
be a global citizen they are imposing a
particular set of values upon you and as
soon as somebody starts to teach values
what they're looking for in the students
again is how the students demonstrated
these values so critical thinking goes
out the window because as soon as
somebody starts
you express doubt so if you take the
issue of climate change of course I
think climate change should be a topic
that's taught in the universities but it
should be a topic where students are
allowed to think critically about it
they can take the data take all the
scientific evidence but then that
doesn't necessarily mean that there's
one right way to interpret that data or
one right way to act upon that data yeah
and as soon as you start moving away
from teaching the science of climate
change to teaching are you were
responsible environmentally a wire
citizen certainly you're moving away
from a kind of scientific rigorous
fatigue to ticking boxes has someone
recycled their coffee cup carton you
know has someone remembered to turn the
lights on I mean we're in LA if you walk
out of here with a class I'll give you a
little warning since you're not related
you walk out here with a plastic bag you
can actually be shot legally they can
just snipers or on the roofs watching
out to to get you Wow so watch out for
that
so the through lines or everything we're
discussing kind of is that there there
really is a political agenda here is
what it seems to me that there is you're
talking about just sort of this very
early on conformity through these kids
and then you throw them into these
colleges now we have any we've gone this
far we haven't even talked about safe
spaces and trigger warnings all that but
you get them they're their critical
thinking skills I've already been
degraded in a certain way
now you inoculate them from a whole set
of other ideas and then you throw them
out into the real world and then they
will be obedient citizens basically is
that a fair through line that I drew
there yeah I'm hopefully some of them
will fight back yeah yeah they hopefully
and I think bright students do and do
begin to think critically and do begin
to challenge although obviously it's far
harder to do that if you haven't got a
basis of subject knowledge on which to
form your critical opinions the only
thing I have to take down a little bit
is I always used to say this thing or
you know when students enter the real
world they will have a shock
I'm not convinced anymore that they will
because you look certainly in the UK at
the way so many laws are enacted to
clamp down on hate speech for example
and hate speech now can be done there is
include encompasses misogyny for example
so if you say a sexist remark or even if
you don't say sexist remark but if you
say something that I interpret as a
sexist remark and I kind of label you as
a misogynist I could go to the police
and say you know you have committed a
hate crime against me yeah are you
familiar with professor Jordan Peterson
at the University of Toronto I had him
on last week and he's dealing with this
in Canada because of a new law that was
passed we're about gender pronouns and
you can really literally report people I
mean exactly what you're saying this is
this is endemic all over the West right
absolutely absolutely so I don't think
unfortunately that there's this big
shock waiting I think what happens is
that the students are taking the
attitudes and the values that they've
picked up on in higher education and
they're then changing the world in that
image but also I think the thing that I
need to remind myself of over time as
well is higher education it doesn't
operate in a vacuum higher education is
kind of part of the worlds as well so
just as we have more censorship but more
so kind of censorious climate and these
clamp downs on hate speech etc in the
real world outside of the university
campus so too does it feed into what's
going on in universities as well I
really find that fascinating cuz I say
that phrase but I remember when my
parents would say it to the other real
world one day you got a college it's the
real world you can't do that anywhere
it's the real world I've used that
phrase about these kids you know that
they're gonna get out of these safe
spaces and they're gonna be in the real
world they're gonna really be screwed
but what you're what you're saying
they're really it is much more dark
depressing because what you're saying is
that this stuff has already taken root
really in the real world so the shock
for them would be if the real world was
different but you're saying it's not
well yeah but I think I'm sorry I might
be jumping ahead a little bit here but I
think they they do still get shocks and
I think you see that is completely this
past week in the reaction to Trump's
victory in the u.s. in the UK we saw it
in the reaction on campus to the vote
for brexit
and you know they will go so far to try
and change the world in their own
so in the UK for example we've had quite
a lot of regulations that have come into
effect in the workplace so if anybody
says anything kind of sexist in the
workplace they can be publicly shamed
for making such comments so these
students will go so hard to try and
change the world as to how they want it
but then every so often yeah these
shocks happen and every soft and I think
like say Trump breaks it bin prime
examples students and not just students
I think even more to the point academics
administrators who are working
universities then have this complete and
utter shock when they're confronted with
the fact that not everybody thinks the
same way as they do right and I think as
we've seen this past week they just
cannot handle that at all rights alright
so let's talk about some of the students
that are that are protesting right now
because it's everyone knows that watch
is this show I am absolutely for free
speech I am absolutely for free
expression I am absolutely for protest
all of those things for sure where I
would draw the line in this case is that
you can't do anything illegal in your
protest so if you're blocking roadways
and stopping ambulances from getting
there or even if you're just stopping
someone from getting to work or going
home or whatever else you can't break
the law you can do it in public places
you can do it in a field your house you
can organise online petitions etcetera
etcetera et cetera what seems scary to
me about what they're doing putting the
legal part aside because they are
blocking roads and things like that is
that they're protesting right now there
they're not protesting an issue so
they're not protesting a specific law
that was passed that they might find
unjust or unfair they're processing the
results of an election that no one is
contesting now we can have a whole
discussion about electoral college and
popular vote but that's not what they're
protesting they're protesting the
results because they don't like them but
I think you would argue that is a very
clear and direct result of everything
that they've been taught so far
absolutely I think you give them too
much credit when you use the word
protesters yeah I mean I've they're
gonna turn me into I'm gonna be a little
darker after I I think it gives them it
kind of gives it too much status to you
and turn this a protest I mean I think
it's something far more
I'm gonna sound like a horrible person
here but I think it's much more akin to
a toddler tantrum I mean I was very
involved with politics when I was at
university but you know we never had
crying we never had Primal Scream's you
know and what you've got is this kind of
outpouring of rage and the thing that
worries me as well and the reason why I
think it's not political and it's not
protest is it's been described in this
very therapeutic language of grief and
healing and a kind of discussion about
the need to share suicide hotline
prevention numbers and and you're
rewarded that way for it right you're
rewarded for you know the more you're
damaged by this I think politics
genuinely has become so confused with
this kind of virtuous signaling and
again you see I think you saw this very
very much in the UK with the whole kind
of leave and remain in the EU thing and
this idea that you your vote to remain
in the EU or thinking in the u.s. you
know your vote for Hillary Clinton
kind of is much more than just evolved
it's much more than just a tick in the
box or you know where you stand on a
particular position it's about you and
you see this in for example Lina guess
what not going to Canada
yeah but this idea is that all of these
things that go on in the world are all
about them it's all about me yeah so if
something happens that I don't like you
know I am devastated I need to heal I
need to grieve I need to cry so the pain
is all about them but the excuse is
always about someone else right because
I even saw Lena Dunham tweeted it
tweeted in the patriarchy and all that
cuz I saw she tweeted just a couple days
ago or right before the election
something about how evil white men and
but my dad was any boy a man and they're
all evil and but and it's like so the
you can revel in the pain yeah that gets
you very high up in your virtues
signaling so that's great but the the
fault is never you're not always the
white absolutely
absolutely sure a really important point
but I think it's not protesting it's
this kind of just outpouring um nebulous
outpouring of nothingness as far as I'm
concerned everything look at me look at
me yeah so I wouldn't I wouldn't gratify
it with the label of a protest but then
I think the second point that you make
is is absolutely spot-on because what
they're essentially doing is complaining
about people I'm complaining about the
decision that people made in that
election box and they're not saying
there's no sense of analysis where did
we go wrong
why didn't we convince people there's no
sense of reflection to think well why
don't people agree with us it's just we
don't like these people who voted
differently to how we wanted them to
vote which is exactly how a democracy is
supposed to work you don't I thought I
don't know if you saw President Obama's
I did I thought it was one of the best
moments of his presidency he said it
doesn't always work this way it doesn't
always work out the way you want it to
work but we have to do this peacefully
and respect the system and I thought wow
this that's maybe I've been too harsh on
the guy because I thought this was so
great what he did completely completely
any and he just come out and said some
very sensible things about the
importance of free speech on campus as
well you know what's quite sad is that
we don't really get that in the UK that
that's steer well sometimes you do I
mean
Prime Minister Therese May she came out
and said the university shouldn't be a
safe space and students shouldn't know
platform speakers but she says that and
I don't know if this is the same with
Obama but trees and mail say that one
day but then she's also have been
responsible for bringing in legislation
it's called the prevent strategy it's
supposed to stop radicalization of
students on campus so she's also being
responsible for an awful lot of the
restrictions that we have in
universities at the moment that who can
say what on the others who can come to
speak on campus so it's not like they
want to react against students but at
the same time they just want their
restrictions on free speech